and now for something completely nuts
birds of prey and the fantabulous
emancipation of one Harley Quinn has had
it's early preview screenings and
audiences have taken to the Internet to
voice their opinions general consensus
the flick is a raunchy funny very gory
good time in case you've missed birds
have praised totally bonkers trailer the
movie follows Margot Robbie's Harley
Quinn following her breakup with Jared
Leto's Joker from Suicide Squad who
doesn't make an appearance in this film
she sucked into some nefarious plot
involving the notorious gangster black
mask played by Ewan McGregor and must
eventually enlist fellow badasses Black
Canary and Huntress to help protect
young Cassandra Cain
Robbie's Harley was one of suicide
squads few bright spots and audiences
have been anxiously awaiting her return
to the role burst of prey is largely
Harley show and those preview audiences
haven't seen a goofy mayhem driven
comic-book character so thoroughly
inhabited by an actor since the last
Deadpool movie let's dig into what they
had to say first things first this isn't
a comic book film that you'll want to
bring the kiddies along for birds of
prey is a hard-r with copious amounts of
rough language and the kind of violence
usually reserved for Saw movies and
alike one Reddit user posted a lengthy
review of the film in which you broke
down just how inappropriate birds of
prey really is for the youngsters right
saying this might be the goriest
mainstream comic book movie I've ever
seen there's a lot of cursing as well
this is a movie that is really not meant
for children it's pretty brutal
I think teens will love this though I
think this will make John wick numbers
as far as just how enjoyable all this
mayhem was the reddit sir was duly
impressed adding it's way better than
Suicide Squad the jokes are funnier I
thought you and McGregor stole the show
the actress who played Cassandra Cain
was also surprisingly good over on
letterboxed one user was enthralled to
see a group of kick-ass women ride
saying the film doesn't make much sense
but all my life I've seen films about
guys fighting without any reason and now
watching girls kicking some asses for
any reason fills you with power is this
what empowerment feels like is that's
what boys feel like when watching those
nonsense films give me more generally
the response to the film so far is
positive but the vast majority of
preview audience members claiming that
as far superior to Suicide Squad which
isn't very hard to do and even belong to
the likes of
the woman and Shazam among the best flex
on the interconnected DC extended
universe it's worth noting that these
audience members tended to exclude Joker
from the discussions as it's understood
to be completely separate from the rest
of DC's offerings another letterbox to
use a wrote margot robbie is amazing as
Harley Quinn and Cassandra Cain steals
all the scenes you and his black mask is
fantastic the character is sadistic and
cruel and he managed to convey all the
essence of the villain it's a good film
one of the best in DC another viewer
concurred while pointing out that the
flick is more than just a reskin of
Marvel's popular r-rated franchise the
user explained the Speights are
confusing edits in the first act and a
slightly flat villain birds have prayed
that levers of fresh take on the
superhero movies field it should not be
reduced to the female Deadpool as this
one has more charm a stronger cast and
distill interconnected to the DC
extended universe finally one particular
audience member on letterboxed weighed
in with an opinion that we're not sure
we can get behind although it is
eloquent in its brevity they said simply
MCU is dead
somehow we doubt that Harley and powers
will be putting the final nail in the
coffin of that franchise but if there's
any doubt that the DCE use course
correction after the stunning failure of
Justice League is in full swing birds of
prey should put it to rest the flick
opens wide on February 7th 2020 check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos buy your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and at the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]